it will we were offered you know it's
very hard to turn something like that
down we're a band that's done almost
every everything it's possible to do you
know with the headline this and we
played there and you know
it was very very hard to turn down
Wembley Stadium though isn't it what an
iconic place you know what an iconic
venue just it's just uh just incredibly
exciting the idea of it so I absolutely
can't wait it's fine so uh you could
always when you played Wembley Arena you
can say we've played Wembley but you
know beat down you haven't Wembley
Stadium's the thing you know it's like
it's like the Buddha Khan or you know
Madison Square Garden it's one of these
iconic places that uh you know that are
on secretly on your bucket list even
though you pretend they're not
I I personally incredibly exciting very
much looking forward to it yes there are
nerves the nerves these days come about
half an hour before show time
so yeah I go from sort of relaxed kind
of sitting around reading a book to
suddenly sitting bolt upright a half an
hour before show time pacing the room
and kind of suddenly going oh my God
whatever can't remember the songs what
if I can't remember how to play